بايديهم وارجلهم وكل ما تيسر من معدات
يقاتل السوريون في احدى معاركهم الكثيره
سكان ومتطوعون يسابقون الزمن في مدينه
حارم وسلقين اكثر المدن المتضرره من
الزلزال في ادلب
عمليات الحفر والانقاذ مستمره فيما وقعت
على عاتق الكثيرين المهمه الاثقل وهي
انتشال الجثث ومرافقتها سواء لتسليمها لمن
بقي من العائله او للمشافي قبل الدفن
الغصه تكبر حين رؤيه الدمار من اعلى رغم
قساوه المشهد على الارض مباني سويت
بالتراب واخرى باتت عاريه لا تسترها نافذه
او باب او حائط لكن حتى تلك يخشى ان تحوي
في احدى زواياها شخصا عاجزا عن النزول
حيده الزلزال فعليق في برد دون كسوه
عواصف شتاء وثلوج ونوبات بحث متواصله
انهكتهم حينا لكنها لم توقف مسعاهم
عالقونا قد يكونون بانتظارهم منذ وقت طويل
وملت اجسادهم الانتظار